the thing that broke me down the most
wasn't the friends i lost in combat was
the friends we kept losing
after it takes its toll made you join
the military
i made a lot of bad choices when i was
in high school
and i needed something that would give
me an opportunity
and a chance when i was a kid there was
a marine that lived around the corner
for me
and he stood tall and he wrecked he was
just so proud
from that day on i knew i wanted to be a
marine i personally would not recommend
my own children
enlist in the military i just feel like
there's a lot of variables that could go
wrong
and i'm not entirely confident that the
government would take care of them
post service some unfair judgments that
i've really seen is
uh in the civilian sector when you come
out there's a lot of
things that you're taught in the
military within your communication that
could be viewed as
aggressive a lot of people assume that
you're crazy or that you have ptsd that
there's something wrong with you
some sort of ticking time bomb that
walks around is just not the case or
that we're all
bloodthirsty savages we're not against
anybody
we're not for anybody where we are
truly of the people by the people and
for the people
[Music]
hey guys what's up danny sharp army
eight years
uh i'm dave i'm a retired marine from
about four or five decades ago
maybe you can't tell by looking at me i
was in marine corps for 20 years
and i worked for the va afterwards and a
couple of other jobs and
here i am my name is mahati and i was in
the u.s army for four years
my name is peter i've been in the u.s
army at
active duty and the reserves for 22
years what's up fellas how are we my
name's elliot i served in the marine
corps for four years
the first prompt is i enlisted at 18
years old
come forward if that's true for you
i enlisted at 18 because honestly
college really wasn't an option for me i
wasn't exactly the most intelligent high
school student i failed
numerous classes i knew that i wanted to
be a marine from a young age
so as soon as i graduated high school
literally five days after i
graduated high school i was on the
yellow footprints in boot camp yeah i
can relate to that i
left two weeks after i graduated high
school
but i had a less than normal childhood
we'll say so
the military was a way that it would
offer me a you know a chance to
have a stable adult life once i um once
i progress
after the military too i was looking to
get away you know i
grew up in here in the south bay area
had a fairly comfortable life
graduated at 17 but they picked me up
from my 18th birthday party
and my first day of being 18 was spent
at uh fort leonard wood in processing
wow that basic so
that sucks yeah you know one hell of an
18th birthday present you know welcome
to boot we're shaving your head
so my story is actually a little
different i
enlisted with the navy when i was 17
and then i failed out of high school the
marine corps took me as far as mcrd
and then they found a heart murmur and i
got sent home i pissed away
a year of my life making awful choices
and
one day woke up and walked downstairs
where my father was waiting in the
dining room and i said
if i don't join the army or the air
force
i am going to end up face down in a
ditch probably in a couple of weeks
because i have nothing
and a couple of weeks later i raised my
right hand they gave me some waivers and
i joined
and i was 19 when i
enlisted and i turned 20 in basic
training wow
i think the beginning of my military was
like yours
i had gotten kicked out of high school
or dropped from the academic roles
because of not
passing three academic subjects which
they told us and so now i'm in
philadelphia walking the streets by
myself no
friends and i went down to the recruiter
and he said you got to get your parents
consent because you're only 17.
he gave me the paperwork so i took it
home and my father signed
right away and so i was off
to the marine corps at 17 and i got out
and
i stayed out for a little over a year
and i went back again and i did three
more years
and i got out again i must not have been
happy
maybe i was confused i came back in
after that
that's more the point you kept coming
back for more
there's something special about being a
part of an
organization where we all went through
the same crucibles you guys literally
right yeah and instantly have a bond
with them
that we just don't have with other
people
my military experience has affected my
mental health
coming out of the military regardless of
the experience you've been through i
mean i
don't know who else has been operated
within
combat zones but the thing that people
don't realize is they look at ptsd they
look at the trauma that we face and that
we see
in those types of environments but they
don't understand
the emotional take
that you that you go through as you just
basically transition
out of the military and you lose a real
part of yourself that family that
connection
being that you're still in yeah how do
you adapt
to having to deal with mental illness
while still being
in the military now when i answered this
question
of i agree with the military has
military services affected my mental
health i mean that in both a positive
and a negative way
the sudden absence of regimentation when
i left active duty and joined the
reserves
was so stark and so difficult
for me to deal with that i
quite literally fell apart i lost my
father in 2009 had a deployment
immediately afterwards
the crazy thing is that the deployment's
what saved me now
there's a positive side to this of
course i don't
feel at any point that it's completely
hopeless there's all like
there's always a fight that can be won
yeah the thing that honestly has gotten
me the the most has been
i didn't realize what i experienced in
iraq would have such a powerful impact
on my life
one of the things that i went through
was my co got killed in iraq
and i unfortunately was not on that
patrol so
i think about it all the time and every
memorial day i think about it every
veterans day i think about it and i'm
thinking about my situation like
i can't believe that only one deployment
did all this to me i came home with ptsd
anxiety depression hyper awareness it's
just a whole laundry list of issues
and i was able to find
my calling in the music industry and now
i'm able to take the platform that i've
been given
and inspire other people it's mental
emotional
physical spiritual strength and
endurance that gets us through i mean
you're not alone i've been there yeah
i've got survivors guilt as well
but you know what got me the most the
thing that broke me down the most wasn't
the friends i lost in combat was the
friends we kept losing
after it takes its toll
first of all i consider myself very
fortunate that
because of my service i didn't
experience any kind of significant
mental health challenges
but because of my job i saw a lot of
people that did whether they're coming
back from deployment
and just messed up by the hell of war or
even
the issues that we have stateside when
we have suicide
murders sexual assault things like that
they're all
affecting the mental health of the force
currently i find
that i have been extremely
concerned and helpful for veterans that
i know
are running that veterans administration
gauntlet
to benefits i don't know if
that's if i was affected
my mental health was affected because i
have this really desire
to want to help guys and women through
this
va gauntlet that they have to go through
which is
amazed to them you know we have a lot of
veteran like our culture in the military
is like hey just tough it out suck it up
suck it up you know yeah um
drink water face out yeah yeah
we kind of carry that into the civilian
world and now you know we're trying to
shift the culture where it's like hey
ask for help you know it's it's not a
sign of weakness to ask for help you
know
i have felt sympathy for those we've
fought
our business that we have had
the titles that we have held have been
a business of trying to prevent the loss
of life
by causing the loss of life it is a
difficult choice
to make to pull the trigger it's the
hardest trigger pull that you'll ever
feel in your entire life is to pull that
trigger with someone on the other end
i could not do my job
as a leader in today's army
if i was not able to see the person
on the other end of my rifle as a human
being
we try to train each and every soldier
marine airmen and sailor that a target
is only a silhouette
to take away that shock value to take
away that burden of responsibility of
what you're about to do
but the inability to sympathize
with another human being would make
our job impossible if someone is hurt
if someone is wounded if someone is
injured if someone is sick
if someone needs to give birth and they
are not wearing an american flag
we will still render that because we
have to have that sympathy we have to
have that empathy
or we can't continue we just can't our
ethics and our humanity are the only
things that really keep us
intact when we're there and allow us to
come back
into the civilian sector and still be
human beings
we're dealing with anxiety we're dealing
with depression
but for the first time that i've seen
you have men and women that have the
capacity
and compassion for themselves to reach
out for help to talk about these events
to bring awareness i'm going to put you
on the spot
you lost your co yeah and that hurts i
lost some friends
when they took him from you what was the
initial response
did you feel the way that i felt that
hate and that rage
immediately when we got the call on the
radio about
the ied that exploded under his humvee
and killed him
i wanted to grab my rifle and run to
where they were and just unload
that anger sat in me for a while
looking back now i'm able to
understand more about maybe why they did
what they did
culture society and i understand that
that is what was the driving force
behind what they were doing
i think we're all privileged to live in
the united states and we have a broader
view
of how the world works around us they
may not
and their idea of good is much different
from our idea of good
i remember being in iraq going on foot
patrols
and i would have sympathy for this the
civilians the citizens of iraq
of ramadi because they would ask us for
basic things like water
soccer balls you know things that we
take advantage of
every single day here and i was sitting
there walking around with my rifle on
patrol thinking
these people don't have these basic
necessities they can't get food they
can't get water
they don't have the kids don't have toys
to play with that must suck
and to to think if i was if this was
my country if i'm in if i'm in los
angeles california and a foreign force
invades
what am i going to do what what would i
do
are you damn right that i would probably
be on the other end of that i would be
the terrorist i would be the insurgent
trying to protect
my homeland and my way of life because
this is how i grew up
i don't know who these people are and
they're trying to impose their will on
me
and i don't want it right you can at
least sympathize with
the lives that are upended because of
this conflict
you know when we talk about the
civilians that have to deal with this
you know
especially in the situation that you
talked about where they
you know don't have what we have you
know like i immigrated from a country
where refrigeration was a luxury
right yeah yeah so um you know it
there's more involved than just you know
the a-side and b-side oh yeah oh of
course
drone warfare scares me
robert e lee who was a confederate
general
during the civil war said it is good
that war
is terrible lest we become accustomed to
it i get it i know i quoted a
confederate general the whole
of the internet is going to explode now
but he has an excellent point
if we do not experience the terrors of
war it will be war without end because
there is nothing to lose
drone warfare terrifies me because it
separates
the human experience of war from the act
of
killing look at dru i mean the only
people who feel the experience of the
drone warfare operators
and they are going through mental health
crisis
left right and center because they stare
at the people's faces and those people
have no idea it's coming none whatsoever
if we lose empathy for the results of
war
we are doomed to repeat it over and over
and over and over and over again
and what do we do when it's on us with
the intelligence
like it is it's so impressive and
precise
that if you take a five-digit grid
coordinates and five digits the other
way
if one digit is wrong you miss the
target and so if the intelligence is off
by the most minor degree you're going to
miss the target
and then you know where where did the
munitions end up where do they land
you know and a big i'm sorry when we get
around to it six months later
so um it's too flaky too flaky and shaky
they made the controllers for some of
our our automated
weapons they turn them into xbox style
controllers
because it's because the argument is oh
because
you know we understand xbox controllers
this generation understands
this this this style of controllers and
it becomes easier and easier and easier
and easier and easier to pull the
trigger and
think that there's no consequence look
i'm sorry i can't even wait till i sit
down
i understand everything you're both
saying about how
technology can affect what can happen in
the world precision strikes all over but
to sit there and
take in my opinion a naive perspective
and saying that
drone technology is going to have such a
profound effect
when it comes to the impact of how we
conduct the business of war
because it is a business at the end of
the day if it can prevent the loss of
life
precise strikes to limit the loss of our
brothers and sisters lives
i am 100 for it the humanity of war of
you taking a life and me seeing that and
the emotional impact of the rest of the
people in that room
versus one person sitting on a computer
who we can keep in a safe environment
and provide mental health
and care for where's the real downside
we are still taking life
regardless but it's being done in a
precise manner
that is actually preventing the loss of
our soldiers lives
i only disagreed because
i'm more in the middle honestly i've
seen the positive and the negative that
can come out of drones like
like you said it's you can minimize the
loss of life by not having a pilot up
there
but i completely agree with what you
were saying where it's becoming
like almost like a video game um so i'm
kind of in the middle
honestly but what's the difference from
you pushing that button
or sitting up there with a mark 19
raining down on a village 40 millimeter
grenades
raining down hellfire there's a
psychological difference between you
doing it and seeing it
in person on the ground versus doing it
from behind or in like a room
from a drone you know i think there's i
like i said i'd have to do a lot more
research and figure out the specifics
but i think there's a psychological
difference between those two types of
kills okay but what you're saying there
is you would rather inflict
more harm and mental anguish on the
soldier
by physically being there by pulling
that trigger
by letting that mark 1940 millimeter
grenade go
right and rip and watch the destruction
they're doing and put them
right into anxiety and depression and
ptsd
versus it being a video game that they
can turn off and begin to function as a
normal human being and not have that
long-term damage but the thing
you're forgetting is it's not a video
game those are real people that they
just killed with that drone
so the psychological effects might be
the exact same they could be
and no i'm very well aware that those
are real people i
i've walked in those deserts i've walked
down the streets i know exactly what
you're talking about
if you're telling me that with your
experience and your ptsd
if you couldn't take that away and put
yourself in a space
to be able to have gone through that
experience and not
dealt with the fallout and the
repercussion the fear
you wouldn't want that if i am fighting
an enemy
that i have no connection to and they
are fighting
an enemy that they have no connection to
what is the incentive to stop
the answer is very clear mutual
self-destruction nuclear technology has
been around for years
so many how many countries in the world
have access to nuclear technology right
now
plenty plenty why hasn't one nuke been
fired
they have been the pakistani indian
border they've thrown them at each other
left and right
left and right yes but on a global scale
realistically
why haven't any of the superpowers
launched why hasn't china i mean your
point is
your point is solid mutually assured
destruction
but the argument still stands why is why
is north korea continually trying to
find
a way to get a missile to our shores to
load it with a payload
because as soon as they can do it from
over there they will
at what point does it stop at what point
do we have people who are not
wearing a uniform who are in control of
the trigger
saying you know what this group of
people today
you don't think there's political and
economic fallout of that
that's going to hit on a deeper scale i
mean realistically
you're talking about hundreds of people
being taken out you got one off kill
situation
i think the uh the cost of dissonance is
actually greater on the political aspect
of this
if a politician can wage war without
sending their troops and i agree with
you like i care about
the health and well-being of our troops
oh i agree with that wholeheartedly that
part of the argument is
is not inclusive yeah but if they're so
easily able to wage war because of drone
technology
then we're again separating ourselves
from that the human cost of it
the military receives too much funding
um i i
can already sense the answers with the
people that don't agree with me
we spend a drastic amount of money
on our department of defense a lot of
that money just doesn't even go to the
troops themselves it goes
to defense contractors and research and
development and
our military is so large and so spread
out
that when you get to the level of the
individual soldier sailor
service member there's not a lot of
money to invest in them personally
especially when you're looking at
equipment or
you know uh healthcare things like that
you know
so we've gotten used to this
conversation where
you know if we if if we don't spend all
this money on the military we're not
supporting our troops
and truthfully i just think that money
could be used
more wisely to invest in our troops
especially when they get out
so that they don't have to face these
battles alone you know what you said
something there that
made me waver yeah okay and i know you
know the pushback
that you were expecting you're right
you're 100 right
spree to core how could you say we need
to cut back on defense spending
right there's a lack of accountability
and transparency that's happening
absolutely it's being hidden under
documents of paperwork they're being
submitted to congress in the senate for
approval
and defense spending realistically were
what how many times
over the next country the next 13
countries combined
yeah you spend more than them yeah it
was the next team
combined exactly especially because
departments within the military right
how many times have you heard use or
lose right oh the end of
the end of the fiscal year is coming if
you don't use the rest of your budget
you risk budget cuts and now you're now
your unit's buying a whole bunch of bs
that they didn't have before or need it
well and the worst part about it is is
we're spending this money and
the common phrase in the military made
by the lowest bidder right you're not
getting quality equipment you're getting
yeah it's tested but it's not the best
piece of equipment you can have based
upon the amount of money that's spent
as as a person who has to make decisions
for a company level and i assist in
making some decisions for a battalion
staff
one of the most frustrating statements
that i hear
when i'm making a training plan or when
i'm doing a maintenance plan
is there's just no funding for that and
what do you mean there's no funding for
that like we got money for this thing
over here yeah well there was funding
for that well
where did that money go that's a
different pot of money how do i get into
that pot of money
you can't touch that pot of money why
can't i touch that pot of money because
it's for this thing
well okay well let's do that thing no it
can't do that why because there's no
money for that
i can't describe the level of
frustration being in the army reserves
and wanting to make my unit the best
possible unit in our region
in our theater and time after time well
we just have to wait because there's no
money for that
one of the things that frustrated me and
that frustrates me now looking back
at how much i was making in the military
and you're not making a lot of money
and going back to what you said it's
like all this money that the us
government has why don't we spend more
on just the paychecks of the members
trans people should be allowed in the
military
i'll be honest i didn't expect this
really yeah me either honestly
why didn't you expect it uh especially
when i was in
uh there's a lot of concern with the
readiness aspect of it
you know uh being able to support
soldiers that are transitioning
things like that right the reason why i
came to the middle is because
as long as they meet the standard and
that it doesn't affect readiness
i see absolutely no problem with it
because the department of defense has
done this before
where they barred gay people women from
certain things and those same questions
were brought up and now they're
integrated into the force
one of my cycles in basic training we
did what we call icebreakers
it's the first time that the soldiers
actually interact with the drill
sergeants where we are not
yelling at them one of the soldiers
stood up introduced
at that time himself and said i am
so and so i have joined because i want
to
get my money for college so that i can
go to fashion design because i really
want to be on rupaul's drag race
and i said all right hey live the truth
kid i don't have a problem with that at
all
you know and that at that time male
soldier came to me later and said
drill sergeant i don't i don't know how
to express
this because i've heard some things
that some tweets went out from a
particular guy who was in charge at the
time who said we're not going to allow
transgendered soldiers in the military
and they
said hey you know i'm i'm transgender i
said listen
what's stopping you from serving what's
stopping you they went to their chain of
command
and the chain of command said well i
mean you do your job and you do it
as well or better than anybody else here
so it doesn't affect force readiness so
start the process she is now serving in
germany in the army
and there has been absolutely no
uh force multiplier loss at all
if the person has joined the military
for the purpose of serving the military
i can't see myself saying you should not
be allowed to serve
as long as we're in the uniform we all
have to put the uniform first and if
they're willing to put the uniform first
and they want to serve honorably then
hell yes who am i saying no when i was a
counselor
a peer counselor at a vet center and i
put together this group and i had a guy
who was a navy corpsman guy was
extremely gay i mean verbally visibly
gay and he was he wanted a place in the
group
and i said okay and then i called
other buddies of mine friends of mine
about this gay guy wants to be in a
group but none of them had an answer
and i went to the one guy i knew got
named carrie murback from las vegas
and he says culmer he says what's the
problem
and after i thought about it i was the
problem right and uh i didn't have any
particular
negative feelings but i kept going
around to try to find somebody to
help me make a decision there was nobody
available because there was no decision
to be made
i know that one of the biggest questions
that is the question of should
transgendered persons serve in the
military comes up quite a bit
the common answers that we receive from
the pushback is well
where do we house them what what
barracks do they stay in the male
they're
the female beers the words they try and
put in our mouths and by they i mean
individuals who have not served or
individuals who are the empty cans that
rattle
so loudly even if they're serving it's
because
they refuse to look at people at an
individual level and what they're doing
and who they are i don't look don't come
to me
and tell me that we can't have trans
soldiers serving because taxpayer money
i don't come to where you work and tell
you how to mow a lawn
all right case closed i would encourage
my children to enlist
why honestly
free education truth
i am forever grateful for the post 911
gi bill
i became a very different
person because of education and
i can't imagine being thousands and
thousands of dollars
in debt right now having to pay that
back adding to what you're saying
i would qualify the statement of i would
encourage my children
by saying the encouragement is there
it's not a force hey you better join
like it's not that it's if you don't
know
what the next steps are if you don't
have a plan and most people don't
they don't know what comes after high
school why don't you go someplace where
they already have a plan
and you can just fit into the plan for a
little bit i want to ask
about your children would you tell them
when they became eligible to enter the
military
would you tell them about assuming
educational benefits are the same at
that time would you encourage them
as a result of the benefits that they
could be entitled to
and if so suppose 20 minutes later a war
starts they have to go to war
how do they deal with that after hearing
from you their dad
the benefits right yeah yeah
realistically i mean
i've got a i've got a daughter who's
gonna be turning 11 and the son that
just turned six
okay and you know just to openly share
um i'm recently widowed
you know so thinking about the build out
and what that looks like for children
you know now being a single parent and
having to look at that
war is definitely something you think
about but at that stage in life you're
gonna have a general idea of who your
child is
who what they're about i was in that
situation
in 99 i joined knowing that kosovo
was a thing that could happen to me
and then it wasn't kosovo and then it
was iraq
and the first thing my father said was
i know what you're about to go into
because he had been in vietnam
military gives us expensive knowledge
that's what we want
the younger generation to have our
children to have we want them to have
the expensive knowledge
the problem with expensive knowledge is
you don't get the benefits of the
knowledge
until you've gone through the experience
and that experience can be expensive
yeah i'm going to pause and bring
mahathi in oh yeah
you were back there look at this little
guy holy crap
yeah i heard him yeah i heard the
chuckle jesus christ
first of all i'd like to say that i
mostly agree with everything that you
guys said you know um
but you know for example like when we
talk about college right
college being outrageously expensive in
this country i think
a more productive way to address that is
why is college in our
country so expensive i'm not sure if as
a parent i would be comfortable
with rolling the dice with my children
when it comes to mental health physical
health injuries you know things like
that
i can provide my knowledge my experience
those that i've met veterans that i've
met
but you know because you want what's
best for your child right and
um so yeah i'm not entirely opposed to
it i guess
you talk about wanting the best for them
but what's the actual feeling you have
on it how do you
genuinely feel about it as an individual
not the parent wanting the best for
their child is this something that you'd
sit there and say
look i get it i support you because i
actually believe in it or i'm going to
support you
because i'm your parent and i see the
other side of it and that kind of gives
me that drawback of
no because yeah no because look i
benefited from the military greatly like
it might i would not be
sitting here the way i am today if it
was not for the military you know so i
totally understand that aspect you know
um but like i said i just i just seen it
go wrong too many times you know like
young people coming back with shrapnel
across their face and
i'm just their life is you know in the
hands of the us government and i'm not
entirely comfortable
with just that aspect of it all right
[Music]
you